who would sign up for that that's pretty
bad man everyone's like this is fake I'm
like I don't know but but but but to be
honest just to be hon I'm a fighter but
it looks all his all his Knockouts look
kind of like set up like he he's making
a lot of money in there right what what
if he just telling these guys all right
I'll give you extra 2 million you just
what did he pay Tommy Fury Tommy Fury
beat him yeah he couldn't pay Tommy fury
because it's different yeah because
Tommy Fury has more clout behind all
right let me ask then what did he pay
Nate Diaz who doesn't did he knock Nate
Diaz out no but beat beat him you think
Nate would agree to fight and get beat
Nate is a good striker in MMA but he's
not a boxer you you really think Nate
would be like yeah I'll take a dive for
you Nate Diaz but did he knock Nate Diaz
out no but if they're all fixed so you
proving my point I didn't say that I
didn't say they were all fixed I'm just
saying what some of them are you think I
just think I'm just saying I don't know
what what what but I'm just saying what
if he com to these guys he ain't fting
two years I give you extra two million
you let mean if you just get knocked out